[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
are you luke you chris
how do i know you're not a cop would a
cop do this
all right you're not a cop but how do i
know you're not wearing a wire
all right if you want to go to my secret
fishing spot
you're gonna have to wear this
all right
nice fishing spot yes sir let's go check
it out
luke and nathan here at the outdoor boys
youtube channel and i've got chris
flores from the muddy river catfishing
channel here
and he is being so kind to hostess at
his
super remote super secret fishing hole
here in new mexico
and we're gonna be camping we're gonna
be fishing
uh we're gonna be braving the cold
because it turns out that new mexico is
not a hot
place it's actually very cold it's 27
degrees here in october
and as you can see it's quite snowy and
we're gonna spend two nights camping
here and
maybe even doing some catch and cook
videos and some awesome campfire cooking
as well so
uh it's gonna be it's gonna be awesome
i'm ready man let's let's do it
now if you guys follow chris flores's
channel
he pulls monster catfish out of this
tiny little river here it's it's one of
the coolest things in the world
i'm excited to see if we can do the same
when it's 27 degrees out
[Music]
the thing's a little cozy but it's just
perfect for me and nathan and
small is good in the wintertime this
should keep us really warm
[Music]
it's a little it's a little lizard he
was hibernating
we need to get some firewood
[Music]
all right got the firewood sorted let's
get a fire going
got my blast match here which is just a
ferrous rod on a spring
there's a steel tab here squeeze this
down
and make sparks well i ran out of jute
and i need something to catch a spark
and turn it into a flame so i need to
find some sort of natural material here
i'm going to try this inner bark here
by the way it is a great way to dull
your knife
all right so the inner bark of this tree
seems to catch a spark and turn it into
flames
i need something that's going to take
the flames and make them bigger
and i've got these bits of cattail
leaves and stem
and i've shredded them up like this
we're gonna have everything
ready to go
there we go
okay
all right i told chris if he would let
me come and crash his super secret
fishing spot
that i would cook and make sure he ate
like a king so we've got some
awesome food coming up and we're in new
mexico right so we're gonna do tacos
and we're also going to barbecue up corn
and do like mexican style barbecued corn
i got some thin cut round steak here and
i've sprinkled rock salt pepper and some
mexican fiesta seasoning on it i'm just
going to set that aside
yeah what kind of monster am i i forgot
cilantro chris
trip's over we're done
mix that around uh put it down
so i'm eating them dig in how you want
all right
okay chris flores's mother made
this amazing salsa here just follow me
too much of anything is not good for you
baby
but i don't know about that
let's check out the corn oh yeah here we
go
look at that corn out of my face
[Music]
okay gonna butter this up
got some mayo some chili flakes
[Music]
there we go we got grilled mexican style
corn here
yeah this is this is doing it for me
[Music]
it works i told chris if i'm gonna lure
him out into this weather and
kill him from hypothermia at least do it
with a full
i'm gonna belly happy i don't see how
they could refuse you know it yeah
nathan sit down and eat your quesadilla
okay
there you go it's dessert time and we
got caramel flan
[Music]
it's going to be flantastic
here we go caramel flan chris i love
flan you love flan
i love flan so much hey nathan you ready
for dessert
what have you eaten nothing
eat it well we've got a belly full of
good food and just had a great time
but uh we've got a little bit of a storm
coming in the weather's getting colder
and we're getting more snow so i'm not
sure how serious this is gonna get but
uh
it's gonna be interesting because we're
here for two nights we'll just see what
happens but uh we're gonna be fishing
all night long
and uh we're gonna be fishing tomorrow
and hopefully we'll catch something
be able to cook up some catfish over
that campfire but
i'm gonna head back to the camp and get
things ready for nightfall
nathan are you having fun yeah even
though my pants are falling down
dipping your apple in your hot chocolate
that tastes
good
all right we're going to roast the
marshmallows we got the special rainbow
flavored ones from walmart these things
are awesome
they just need to catch on fire then
then they cook
festival yeah they do well it's been a
great day and the snow is coming down
properly we're getting some
accumulation but i gotta get to bed
well it's a bit cozy in our little
one-man tent here but it sure is warm
i'll see you guys in the morning guys
it's 6 30 in the morning
and me and chris are just getting
started and uh we got a fish on one of
the rods
huh
oh come aboard
nice blue cat looks like the catfish are
just as crazy as us getting out in this
weather
oh this is a perfect size eating catfish
man so i think we're gonna be having
catfish tacos tonight why don't you come
join us for dinner i can
feel heat
i went and gathered some standing dead
wood because it was less covered in snow
and i'm just going to put it right here
on top of the coals let it warm up a
little bit because warm wood
ignites better
good morning nathan did you sleep well
warm last night
yeah there you go buddy chocolate muffin
i'll just take one for now okay
put some on the bacon there you go man
breakfast is champions
chris is shoveling off the boat and we
are going to hit the water
and explore the river bit and see if we
can't catch some of these big monster
catfish
chris is always catching now in case you
guys don't know
chris here has a really awesome
catfishing youtube channel called muddy
river catfishing and he also does
a guide service here in new mexico so if
you guys want to go on a guided fishing
trip here in new mexico or if you want
to check out more fishing videos
i'll put a link to chris's stuff in the
video description
what was it whipped cream
you got a little whipped cream on your
there you go chris you want some oh
you're good
all right i'm ready to go vision
there's a cab
[Music]
[Music]
way back there
rod tips are good
somebody's done this before a couple of
times
all right is this where we this is where
we start fishing i like using the paddle
as a cutting board that's a nice
that's a nice space-saving technique
shad allah or
with the sprig of cat tail i met up with
chris a day or so before we came out
here
and we went to the rio grande and chris
threw his cast net in these little pools
left over from where the
river waters went down caught a ton of
bait it was actually really fun
oh yeah i want to show you something i
want to see his tail talent
banana
[Applause]
i made cattail man and he loves you oh
you made it for me i made it for you to
a basket or something
he now has the spear of justice
are you covering me in fluff we've had a
lot of bites and a couple fish on but
haven't landed much but we're gonna go
back get some lunch and
pick this up again after lunch
well you're making it look easy chris
daddy
a bit of steak
fried onions
well then some italian style cheese
yeah you like that
yeah all right guys we've got
belly full of food and we are gonna go
try another shot of these catfish
and we've gotten a ton of nibbles but
not really anything hooked up so
we're gonna reel it in head back to camp
before it gets dark we got a catfish to
clean
gorgeous river thank you really is
hold on nate
we are going to make catfish tacos
tonight i want to go ahead and clean up
that catfish and start cooking
all right we got our catfish fillets and
i'm gonna put some of this
blackened catfish seasoning here and go
heavy
now let's go get a frying pan really hot
time to fry yeah
okay
oh hold it you got it you got it hold it
strong all right
black and catfish with pico de gallo and
avocado
what do you think of the catfish nathan
i like it
yeah we got it with some green chili
salsa
you know nathan it's it's past your
bedtime buddy
these are some warm jammies
are you gonna watch some cartoons
tonight
okay well nathan's to bed and i don't
know if you guys can hear this
but there's a whole pack of coyotes
howling at the moon
over the desert over there it's just
it's pretty cool but we're just kind of
taking it easy
and uh relaxing and straighten up the
camp and
i'm gonna be turning in here in just a
little bit
good morning nathan
well it's cold enough to have frost on
the ground but warm enough for nathan
to not have pants on and i need to get
him into his pants
but they're kind of cold so i'm gonna
i'm gonna warm them up here
[Music]
all right does that feel warm yeah
[Music]
all right warm tortilla couple strips of
bacon
okay pork sausage and onions
explores his mama's green chili salsa
buttered scrambled eggs there we go
breakfast burrito
would you rather have my delicious
handmade breakfast burrito or cup of
noodle
noodle all right knock yourself out bud
i'm i'm teaching you a secret of arctic
survival
oh yeah it's all about the blubber i get
that blubber layer gotta
gotta get that blubber later man
nathan did you have a good time yeah
thank you so much for hosting us hey
thank you for coming out
and if you guys enjoyed this video as
much as we enjoyed filming it
make sure to click subscribe to the
outdoor boys youtube channel and check
out chris flores's youtube channel
muddy river catfishing i'll put a link
in the description and if you want to
see a video of me going with him on a
guided fishing trip on elephant butte
then check out the link in the
description i'm going to be posting that
on my other youtube channel
the catfish and carp youtube channel
thanks for watching guys
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
saturday morning
and hit that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for
boy watching plan was good i wish we had
plan